what should I say during sex this is a
fun one
[Music]
[Applause]
hi hello how are you good I'm Rabbi
Mendel Simons so nice to meet you nice
to meet you
I want to get married with my boyfriend
but I hate his parents they lack
boundaries and can often be rude to us
how important is it to have a good
relationship with potential In-laws in
my culture in Malaysia marriage is not
just between two persons it's also
meeting two families I do think that
having a good relationship with your
in-laws is very important now that said
I know for a fact that some of our
families want to dictate how the couple
should live how the children should be
raised etc etc there needs to be
boundaries I'll tend to agree with what
you said at the same time if the option
is like choosing me or your parents that
I think that's a recipe for disaster if
you truly love someone you have to learn
to at least engage and be involved in
their parents life I'd find a way to
like them like everybody's got likable
factors about them is cheating a deal
breaker or should they get a second
chance it's not acceptable is it a deal
breaker meaning if you're married
already with kids 100 you should try to
work it out we believe in forgiveness
you may never get back to what you had
before but it was a second marriage with
the same person that you could create
spot on I don't have anything else dad
forgiveness it doesn't mean it's easy no
and not always possible how do you
prepare a person outside of your
religion to meet your parents my
favorite question
we should probably talk about who's
going to officiate the wedding oh Arnold
already talked to Rabbi singer singer is
in yeah he'd be honored
Rabbi singer
so you're not gonna go with an Iman
mine's gonna be short okay go ahead
I don't because we don't do Interfaith
yes I've done a lot of interfaith
marriages and the way that I've been
able to overcome some of these hurdles
is actually to bring together the common
denominators in the theology so there
was a time in my life where I thought no
my daughter needs to marry Muslim and
then I realize there's a lot of good
people out there regardless of their
religion even atheists I just want my
daughter to marry a good guy someone
who's going to truly love her and take
care of her you said your oldest is 14.
yeah a daughter yeah what would your
reaction in a portray if she was falling
in love with someone outside of your
religion I'm not sure it's like I'm
gonna have to cross that bridge when I
get there I don't plan on getting there
but I'm also not arrogant enough to
think that it's impossible to happen
I've seen relationships couples where
the parents have disowned the child
because they've married outside the
faith but then they reconcile his
parents age I find that they tend to be
much more forgiving and much more
willing to to accept things as they are
I'm 18 and I've never kissed anyone how
do I stop feeling like there's something
wrong with me I never kissed anyone when
I was 18 either the feeling that there's
something wrong with you is based on a
false belief a false premise that your
identity or that who you are as a person
comes down to whether you kiss someone
or not destroy it get rid of it it's not
true
I have kissed someone by the time I was
18 so
pressure that children and teenagers and
youth have is immensely negative I think
it's really important not to be
influenced by your environment the value
that you need to have kissed someone is
going to drive you to go kiss someone
that's not very important and it's going
to make that first kiss not a very
valuable one not a very meaningful
fulfilling one destroy that premise by
the time you do kiss someone it'll be
with someone very special what should I
say during sex
this is a fun one
so I think it really depends on the
individual and the individual
spirituality even my gut's going to tell
me that the height of intimacy
experiences when you're completely out
of your head
and in your body
and just submitting to instincts the
mind is not involved in great sex let's
just put it that way how do I escape
dating apps the apps are really toxic
but it's the only way I get validation I
would say you might have to go cold
turkey on this one the app is just the
Matchmaker and once you meet that person
maybe delete all the apps some of the
couples that I've married they've met
through an app my daughter is one of
them too so there have been some
successful relationships but I do think
that there are other ways of meeting
people by way of relationship building
by common interests right so you don't
have to rely on these dating apps like
try to find Community try to go out and
meet people versus only meet people over
the phone I'm a 21 year old virgin it's
not that I don't feel ready for sex but
I haven't met anyone who's offered it
without acting to sus most guys seem to
give me the ick I think I'm pretty well
versed but I don't know what the ick is
me neither put off by them yeah yeah
okay am I being close-minded I'm very
horny but don't want to make a decision
that I'll regret sexuality is not a
sport that should be an act of bonding
and connection with someone you truly
care and love society's very proud of
the hookup culture and thinks it's
liberating but a lot of people report
feelings of loneliness feelings of
unfulfillment have it with the right
person and you just hopefully experience
the beauty of what it is I understand
she's feeling pressured like am I weird
but for being 21 and being a virgin I
would caution about jumping into the
sack with someone just for the sake of
it right it is a very spiritual
experience well in regards to the second
question about being horny
well there are always tools that you can
relieve yourself there's nothing wrong
with masturbating the last thing you
want to do is to be anxious about not
being sexually active which is worse
parents trying too hard to be done with
the kids to win over their child's lover
or parents intentionally making life
difficult for their child's lover as a
way to test their suitability they're
not engaged yet and they're just kind of
in a relationship then I think it's
healthy to test a relationship in an
appropriate way obviously in a way that
is really trying to understand your
child's lover rather than being abrasive
or aggressive there's an approach to
everything if I can share something
personal you know she's had a boyfriend
where we completely disagree with who
did not like did not approve but we did
not tell her that right at the end of
the day she's going to have to make that
decision like I do as a rabbi when
people come to me and ask me advice for
something I never give them a direct
answer about what they should or should
not do so if you could guide them in
that way that might be the healthiest
approach parents obviously have to hold
back and give themselves a reality check
too and let their kids make their own
decisions and that's what I'll hopefully
try to do in my own kids if I see a red
flag like I have a really hard time
breaking up with people and staying
broken up what is your advice for
detaching yourself from someone you
loved so much at one point it's not an
easy exercise
particularly in social media world and
so I think it's just a it's a matter of
removing those physical evidence or
social media evidence of of that person
it's perfectly okay to miss someone that
you're not supposed to be with that's
the part that gets very confusing for
people they're like I'm missing them so
did I make a mistake was I supposed to
be with them you had a close deep
relationship with this person that's not
so easy just to undo keep less focus on
what you're going away from and more
focus on what you're going towards how
do you know he or she is the one
honestly I don't know what love is it's
a gut feeling in my particular case and
I think it's different for everyone
obviously that said I do think that it's
really important for you as an
individual to know yourself first
because once you're there you will be
attracting the right person to you
choosing the right one is a leap of
faith at some point you're never gonna
fully know but there can be certain
things in place and self-awareness is a
key one the most important thing that I
think most people are missing before
they try to choose somebody is
understanding what a relationship and
what a marriage is once you're fully
aware of that and you're fully aware of
self you're ready to make that choice of
who that person is love is not an easy
Journey but it is definitely worth it
we're gonna have you guys watch a
trailer for Netflix's new movie coming
out new people are you ready to watch it
yeah yep
you're dating a black girl I've never
felt so understood by somebody in my
entire life I'm gonna ask her to marry
me do you plant it that's where family
yeah I just haven't had the chance to
meet them what's going on tell me about
life how are you
this is your white granddaddy come back
and haunt me what
you want to marry my daughter
yes you could try
oh so you're all Muslim very much so I
love it this kufi that I'm wearing was
actually a gift from The Honorable Louis
Farrakhan are you familiar with The
Minister's work well I'm familiar with
what he said about the Jews you know
let's have dinner are you trying to
compare the Holocaust to slavery we lost
the potatoes our people came here with
nothing like everybody else they're very
uncomfortable conversation you can never
figure out what happened with the
potatoes
oh my God it's gonna be funny that's
great if either of you experienced any
kind of similar situation to that
trailer
yeah
I am so glad you're making this movie I
have no idea I know from my constituency
and the couples that I've the Interfaith
couples I've married I think this is
gonna be so refreshing to see it in
comedy I think it's actually a really
good medium
um to be doing this because it is a very
difficult subject matter such a joy to
meet you yes likewise what a great
conversation
hey good humans thanks for tuning in to
this special episode in partnership with
our sponsor Netflix for their latest
release you people it's all about how
families and cultures Clash went to LA
Millennials from different backgrounds
fall in love and face the ultimate
relationship test meeting the parents
be sure to check out you people now
streaming on Netflix